de l'autre rive une apparition au mahdi
un grand guerrier un esprit qui marchent
t'aidera dans sa quête un homme passé de
l'autre côté puis revenu j'aurais
préféré quelqu'un dos mais je n'ai pas
douté du grand esprit très bien mais si
on fait équipe c'est pour la justice
justice ce que je cherche que moussa b
imagine tout un continent relié par le
rail
celui qui sont rendra maître sera maître
du futur face à un tel pouvoir
les empereurs et les rois passeront pour
des idiots
vous avez un problème avec les indiens
c'est drôle très drôle on accomplit rien
son sacrifice on peut éviter la guerre
arrêtez ce train rien ne peut l'arrêter
vous le savez très bien si ces sommes
représentent la loi je préfère être hors
la loi
pour le cheval de fer est lancé
ni très difficile de l'arrêter
on s'est égaré c'est ça je m'en doutais
ça pourrait être pire
qu'est-ce qui peut y avoir de pire
d'accord c'est pire